night after night
these are the scenes that may come to
define jerusalem's ramadan of 2021.
since the first night of the holy month
palestinians have been protesting
against the closure of the steps
outside damascus gate where they would
usually gather after prayers
they don't allow to the people to sit on
the step
steps to drink something to do they want
to change everything
and we don't forget it's a capital of
palestine and it's still
under occupation every day there are
clashes and it is turning to war i live
here at soleiman street and i can barely
reach home
there is now a real danger of further
escalation with the added element of
far-right jewish groups seeking to
confront the palestinians
on thursday supporters of one such group
marched to damascus gate
chanting death to arabs the two groups
facing off for several hours
with more than 125 people injured mostly
palestinians
in violence with security forces it
follows last month's electoral success
for an alliance of religious
nationalists
and the far-right descendants of one
party banned in the 1990s
for anti-arab racism their leaders have
been sharing videos of palestinians
attacking jews
and repeating pre-existing calls for the
quote disloyal palestinians
to be expelled israel's prime minister
has held an emergency meeting with his
top security officials
we are maintaining the freedom of
worship for all residents and all
visitors to jerusalem
we currently demand that the law be
complied with and i call for calm on all
sides
the focus for concern for israel though
is gaza on friday night armed factions
fired 36 rockets from the strip towards
israel
several more followed on saturday night
israel carrying out airstrikes in
response
the military wing of hamas which governs
gaza expressed solidarity for the
protesters in east jerusalem
the violence has also spread to the
occupied west bank
all of this a month before planned
palestinian elections
which could hinge on whether israel
allows voting in occupied east jerusalem
conflict in jerusalem has in the past
sparked conflict elsewhere the 2014 gaza
war
being one example the current mix of
tension about
race religion and politics has already
led to the biggest gaza escalation
in many months it's a dangerous mix
ensuring tense days ahead
harry fawcett al-jazeera west jerusalem